Cтворення Вищого антикорупційного суду - одна з головних вимог
учасників акцій протесту в Києві.
Та міжнародної спільноти, зокрема - Євросоюзу та МВФ.
Суд має виносити вироки у справах про корупцію,
які розслідуються Національним антикорупційним бюро.
Лише за наявності такого суду Україна отримає наступні транші кредитів та фінансової допомоги.
В останні дні 2017-го Адміністрація президента України
внесла на розгляд Верховної Ради проект довгоочікуваного закону.
І він одразу ж наразився на критику антикорупційних активістів.
Головна претензія - принцип відбору суддів.
Усупереч рекомендаціям Венеціанської комісії,
проект закону не надає Громадській раді міжнародних експертів вирішальної ролі у відборі.
Контроль над процесом залишається за Вищою кваліфікаційною комісією суддів,
а отже - за Банковою.
Друга проблема - завищені вимоги до кандидатів у антикорупційні судді.
Суддівського, юридичного або наукового стажу - замало.
Кожен кандидат повинен мати великий юридичний досвід
у боротьбі з корупцією в міжнародних організаціях і судах,
володіти найкращими світовими практиками у сфері протидії корупції тощо.
Вимоги непогані, але вони суттєво звужують кількість потенційних кандидатів
і заблокують якісний відбір.
Крім цього, президентський законопроект розмиває юрисдикцію антикорупціного суду.
Вона не повністю охоплює справи, що їх розслідує НАБУ,
водночас поширюється на випадки,  не пов'язані з корупцією.
Це може заблокувати роботу Вищого антикорупційного суду,
бо завалить його надто великою кількістю справ.
Венеціанська комісія чітко вказує, що юрисдикція суду
повинна відповідати підслідності НАБУ і Спеціальної Антикорупційної Прокуратури.
Висновок "Transparency International Україна", Центру протидії корупції
та антикорупційної групи "Реанімаційного пакету реформ" - песимістичний.
Президентський законопроект №7440
робить неможливим створення незалежного, аполітичного
і незаангажованого Антикорупційного суду,
не відповідає ключовим рекомендаціям Венеціанської комісії.
Замість цього створюється ще одна судова установа,
вразлива до тиску з боку можновладців.
Фактично саботується сама ідея
незалежного суду для розгляду справ топ-корупціонерів.